so we went through a bit of messy
algebra but that's okay I heard if
everything we got in this spot you're
starting to recognize something right by
the time you had to start completing
this way let our I've seen this kind of
problem before it just came out meetup
right because you often would have
gotten the same numbers here things
would divide through okay what does this
look like yeah like this kind of thing
like this is what I'm familiar with if
for example if I took away the four in
the three just take away these
coefficients for a same right what would
that give you you've got a server with a
particular Center at a particular radius
yes but because you have four and A
three right what's happened is you're
squeezing in you're squashing but you're
doing the horizontal and the vertical by
different amounts in other words what
you get is something in this particular
one I think you'll get something kind of
like this well I'm exaggerating in other
words the shape you have well you gotta
call an oval or could be technical info
and lips okay now this is this is an
ellipse servers in fact this ellipse is
this ellipse no there's whispering
galleries really look at us now this
arch up here is an arc in
who lives right that's how it pulls off
this trick it's because it borrows it
from the circle except that's stretching
it out and does something a little bit
different you remember those people they
had to stand like where they were
standing was not like it was it like
that particular points like this they
can stand sort of community and you move
the diagram transparency okay so let's
get a picture of this ok now I need a
bit more space and you might need to get
a new page
if any top one I think we got it also if
if it were a semi stuff you have to be
so standing up in the air to me all and
also you will never fit as many people
in it and you'd have to make it to tour
like I particularly because on the
ground
I
what I'm making do for me now is you
remember you've gotten two equations of
to LA Kiss's ok ok I would like you to
very roughly sketch the mound for dinner
to be beautiful ok you can see you're
going to have this point here like the
center of the lips is getting higher I'm
going to give you a rough idea of what
it looks like but you'll need two sets
of axes ok so I'm going to go to
traveler then we're going for the others
now it doesn't need to be super detailed
I only want to make a really simple
observation off of this in fact I don't
even want you to buy the labeling the
equation of the wandering like that this
is all you need to see okay now remember
the way we constructed this parabola or
as we gave our lock its definition right
we started with the focus and the
directrix and then we said look if you
compare some distances here right like
this distance this distance or whatever
those should be the same okay then we
change the ratio of those two distances
right we said is instead of making them
the same instead of making the ratio of
one to one we said well let's make a
ratio or half so one of those things is
double the other one okay this is what
happens this is the kind of shape that
emerges I've got this vertical shift
happening which is why I'm kind of
offset I'm okay now though I've got a
completely different shape do you notice
i started with the same two geometric
features i started with the same focus
and saying directrix right so these two
geometric features belong on this shape
as well here roughly here and here
but you'll notice all the lips and drank
just like also all ellipses have this
beautiful symmetry right they are two
particular axis of symmetry and they
have an axis century that relates to
these two features right because you've
got the directrix for instance on this
side right but if this chain is
symmetrical if I look at it like this
sort of to a mirror do you see that it
is a direction on this side there's also
a directrix on the other side that is
equally valid right it's like what makes
this the directrix more this the answer
is nothing if I say there's that
directrix for this focus there's going
to be a second directrix and there's
also going to be a second focus right so
because of the symmetry of the ellipse
as a person essentially the crab are you
really on one Exodus imagery here but I
have to hear right if I cut right down
the middle I get not one but two we call
the prayer time that's a bit more
quickly that's okay and directrix is a
much clue clear kula plural these are
all
Eric director sees very direct uses ok
so what we just establish so far okay we
can now see through just a slight little
modification and we're not all the way
there yet this is just the beginning we
can now see how this IV ellipse or at
least half moons and it's got the
parabola they are deeply connected
algebraically even though like the
equations are quite different now by the
way remember I started off by saying
this you mate you know these two people
they're not just standing anywhere they
are not just stating a two random points
in fact they have to be standing at the
third cut which is the beautiful thing
about the Whispering Gallery you ever
they were standing there in the middle
recording that left oh just take you to
the video of the camera and so on right
and they weren't getting that whispering
of them that's because if you want
anywhere else you sound just doesn't
think it just goes everywhere and it
scrambles right but if you stand at
those particular spots you get this
exact effect
which is another thing as a beautiful
no like
correct that's right so you can see the
arc it actually doesn't like the shape
of the arc you can go back and look at
the video again and you can actually see
the plans for it you go to go to
Wikipedia look up whispering gallery
right and you will see there are many
different varieties and they have to do
some really [ __ ] bouts to get the
positions right because I believe now
actually standing out of a pillar and
infer the odds are ok now just give you
a moment to get some space while I do
this hopefully to do
ok
this is
okay now other the photocopy I'm giving
you and I probably will not do this for
the future this is the new edition of
the small red Fitzpatrick that you
already have some of you might have this
book if I recall the exercise on context
is not actually very different some of
the chapters particularly on integration
gym later papi they are like that's then
they are completely different verses are
from this to the whole edition so that's
why sometimes i will refer this one you
may recognize the typesetting this is
where we've got the contact numbers
exercises from i actually am going to
assign some questions from the other
textbook but I left it on my desk so I
all right now don't worry it's a triple
period I have time now yeah here's way
my challenge every time okay what we did
was we started with in the first place i
dropped off all the way enough food to
grow so much of it we started with our
focus and inner directions and then we
move forward and we got the equation of
the parabola ruler the equation of this
ellipse if you can start with the focus
and directories
and then / forward it the equipment
logic would imply that I can also go in
the reverse direction if what I am
handed is the equator of such a shame if
you know for example and we look at this
before if you know the equator papa
we're quite well versed in working out
what is the equation of sorry again what
is the equation of the metrics of the
focus that bull ball with this guy right
I want you to think for a moment and to
go back to your working or what you just
did to go in this direction if I handed
this to you could you try and work out
well how do i reverse-engineered is how
do i go back and summative the focus and
religious and also know that you will
find two of each you'll find two foci
and you plan to direct races i watch
it'll look carefully at the algebra that
took you from these two features to this
equation I provided a simple one for you
so it's not like all just around among a
bit disgusting so this comes out quite
nicely I wonder if you can work out
where did it come from
and I'm looking for the two foci and the
two director essex they're really if you
find one of each you will be able to
find the others and I'll show you